what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and other awesome things
as well i'm your host warren thompson
and doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is now in theaters and a lot of
fans truly love the movie and honestly
it's really hard not to with some of the
scenes that are in this movie and if you
have not seen doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness we are going to be
talking about spoilers and for those who
say but simply saying that professor x
is in the movie is a major spoiler no
it's not they teased him in the trailer
you heard his voice and literally saw
his chair and he was at the world
premiere of the movie so there you go
and according to patrick stewart himself
he might not actually be done playing
professor xavier and could return to
play him once more in the mcu and it
looks like wanda is not done either as
elizabeth olsen has talked about
returning to play the scarlet witch and
what happens next and we have a report
stating that a solo movie is coming so
obviously we have to talk about that
ending because this kind of goes against
what we saw so let's break down these
reports and talk about what they mean
for the future of the mcu and of course
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel videos so obviously we have to
talk about the ending of multiverse of
madness because it seemed like the
scarlet witch slash wanda had died
however of course we did just watch a
movie titled multiverse of madness and
the multiverse anything is possible and
of course you know the marvel rule if we
don't physically see them die then there
is no guarantee whatsoever that they
have actually died now sometimes this
happens and we never see those
characters again but the golden rule is
if you don't see them die they can come
back and it looks like the scarlet witch
slash wanda is indeed coming back
because elizabeth olsen is already
saying things like she has ideas for
what future projects involving the
scarlet witch could be like she said
that there's a couple of different
versions of what could happen with wanda
after multiverse of madness and she says
i want to hear what the fans who know
her best what they would like to see
from her next so this pretty much
guarantees that she's not dead and if
you go back and you watch the movie
again at the very end when she is
collapsing wundegor mountain on top of
her we see the first part in the throne
room that's close up on her we see some
boulders and stuff kind of fall on her
but then it zooms out way out to where
you kind of just see the whole entire
structure on top of the mountain fall
down but if you look closely at that
moment when the structure falls down you
can see a beam of chaos magic a red
burst of light kind of shoots out and if
i had to guess i'm assuming this is
probably wanda surviving somehow either
that's her teleporting herself her going
and destroying the darkhold and all of
these other multiverses which we do know
that she did whatever happened there i
think that was where wanda escaped wanda
did her job she destroyed the birthplace
of the darkhold and all of its ancient
texts that was on the walls she also
destroyed the dark hole in all of the
other universes which i hope they
actually explain and now she can kind of
do whatever she wants because you have
to realize that wanda didn't actually
really do anything to our universe now
she messed up the illuminati's universe
big time and we're about to talk about
that when we talk about professor x but
i don't think they're going to be many
repercussions to our earth 616 universe
because again nothing really happened
everything that happened kind of took
place in the other universes with the
exception that you know the scarlet
witch did kill some sorceress but to the
public's eye and our universe she's not
a villain they didn't see all of this
happen she didn't do anything to earth
so she can continue to live her life but
as far as what is going to happen next
well there are rumors that we are going
to be getting a true solo scarlet witch
movie now these rumors have been
actually out for a while now the biggest
rumors being that elizabeth olsen
actually signed a new contract with
marvel studios for multiple scarlet
witch projects of course one of those
being a solo film and recently the
insider account my time to shine hello
that has been extremely accurate with a
lot of things concerning the mcu has
confirmed that a solo scarlet witch
movie is in the works which is truly
great news because myself and i think
the vast majority of fans truly love
elizabeth olsen as wanda slash the
scarlet witch and since she was the
villain in this movie i'm assuming that
her solo film is going to be one where
she is not the villain but has a main
villain of its own now they did mention
c'thon in multiverse of madness and in
the comics that is where she gets her
powers from and we also know that the
high evolutionary is going to be the
main villain of guardians of the galaxy
vol 3. and in the comics the high
evolutionary kidnaps her and her brother
does experiments on them and then
returns them to their original parents
plus not to mention mephisto is still a
character that can be introduced in the
mcu that has a very deep connection to
wanda and her children so there are
definitely some options out there but
what would you like to see from a
scarlet witch solo movie and since the
rumor is she signed a deal for multiple
projects that most likely means she's
going to be in a group project so
perhaps she could be in another avengers
film or perhaps she could be in
something like the midnight suns what
would you like to see her be in in the
future and now of course to talk about
professor xavier patrick stewart made
his return as the iconic professor x and
unfortunately he met a very very bad
demise from the scarlet witch in the
film along with the rest of the
illuminati and side note reed richards
did say that he has children and that
his wife is still alive of course that
would be sue storm and in the comics his
son is franklin richards one of the most
powerful mutants ever an omega level
mutant so i have to wonder if his son is
ever going to seek revenge on the death
of his father and start to travel the
multiverse but i'll talk about that
another time let's talk about what
patrick stewart has recently said about
returning to play professor x again in a
recent interview with variety patrick
stewart talked about his future as
professor x he confirmed that after star
trek picard season 3 he is done playing
john luke picard but he is keeping his
options open for professor x in the
interview he said charles xavier yeah
there may be you know the whole x-men
comic series is so huge so vast there
might be an opportunity in which he
comes back we'll see this is incredible
news and yes he did die in multiverse of
madness but hey we know the multiverse
contains multiple professor xavier's so
patrick stewart could return as any one
of those and hopefully they can stop
killing him i'm tired of watching him
die on screen this should be the last
death that we have to see but maybe he
could even play the main professor
xavier in the main mcu now i have to
admit he is pretty old to be playing
this character that might require a
pretty big commitment of 10 plus years
probably 15 plus years plus they'll
probably want a younger professor xavier
but hey the multiverse is now a part of
the mcu in a very big way and it looks
like there's going to be more
multiversal hopping in loki and probably
a lot of other projects coming so
perhaps we see him again as professor
xavier in another universe relatively
soon in the mcu i personally really
would love to see this and maybe he
could even teach dr strange a thing or
two but what's really interesting is the
fact that he's saying this is way
different than what we heard him say
about two years ago now obviously we
know that he was lying because he was in
multiverse madness but at the time he
admitted that he met with kevin feige
and kevin feige pitched certain ideas
for professor xavier to make his return
now patrick stewart said that he put the
character to rest and that he wouldn't
play that character anymore but then we
saw him in multiverse of madness so we
know that wasn't true and we know that
he talked to kevin feige about the
future of professor xavier so perhaps
the plans for him to return are already
in place if so how would you like to see
patrick stewart's professor xavier
return to our marvel cinematic universe
and let me know what you would like out
of the future of the scarlet witch and
wanda in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
marvel videos for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof